à toi de jouer quasiment
mais attend françois ne bouscule pas je
réfléchis en mai à la belote il faut
jouer vite il faut jouer vite bon tu vas
voir
vos notes rambo lot et d'isner
bravo casimir vient jouer tu as gagné
casimir salut françois joe recteur ou
mais à quoi jouez vous là bas à la
belote factor voulait refaire une petite
avec nous a pour sûr ça me ferait
plaisir casimir mais je suis en service
françois j'ai une lettre pour vous il ya
ces facteurs plaît vous aimez les jeux
de cartes poursuit retenait son bureau
de poste le jour souvent avec le chef à
la bataille à la bataille moi ça j'adore
la bataille pas scott c'est très
difficile et il faut réfléchir une
bataille rude bataille
ça c'est du sport à un sport moins
fatigant que de porter des lettres toute
la journée un haut même monsieur le
facteur par ce temps là c'est une
promenade
ben il fait un petit peu trop chaud pour
ce genre de promenade si vous voulez mon
avis ne dit pas ça devant nos amis
facteurs y en a beaucoup qui n'ont pas
la chance de vivre comme nous sous un
soleil toujours à dire ah c'est vrai
c'est vrai regardez il y en a qui ont de
gros chandail mais après tout 20 soleil
nuages qu'importe l'important c'est
d'avoir chaud au coeur
mais cette réponse que vous venez de
dire la factory ma mère me le disait
souvent quand j'étais petit bon tout ça
c'est pas tous mes amis et moi je vais
tourner à continuer alors amusez vous
bien à bientôt acteur d'un tour pour
voir bon françois tu veux bien lire ta
lettre à haute voix le nom soit
quasiment quotidiennes et discret
cette lettre ne t'ai pas dresser les
pour moi mais hors enfin françois tu es
tu es mon ami un oui bien sûr il est
convenu que je suis ton ami aussi et
sans doute mais où veux-tu en venir car
alors il ya de vrais amis n'ont pas de
secret l'un pour l'autre c'est un oncle
archibald qui te disent ah non non c'est
toi qui m'a dit ça un jour bon alors on
tue la ligne aux problèmes que les
cévennes autrement
c'est du fabricant de ballots
cher françois je compte absolument sur
vous la semaine prochaine pour venir
visiter mon usine de balle au chic alors
tu m'emmènera avec toi aussi tu veux
attend il reste une petite phrase après
la signature en porter un gros chandails
ici il ne fait pas chaud mais personne
n'a de chandails dans l'île aux enfants
il fait bien trop beau j'ai une idée
allons voir julie elle va nous en faire
elle tricote très bien bonjour julie
jean gillet face à lui françois salut
casimir un venez pas me dire que vous
avez besoin quelque chose à ça n'est pas
le moment ainsi jusqu'en europe il faut
rester au chaud en train de faire la
lessive de mon casque et je vous assure
que ça n'est pas drôle du tout bon et
bien tant pis puisque l'on ne peut pas
compter sur elle je le ferai moi-même
mais mais voyons casimir tu ne seras
jamais cij je me débrouillerai tu crois
hélas la boudeuse de quoi s'agit-il eh
bien les voilà donc des pâtes ou
l'essentiel des écoutes julie faut quand
même qu'on puisse j'accepte seulement il
faudra que vous aillez lessive etc nos
kiosques oh là là ça va être long on
peut du tout 3,5 heures suivant le train
de rire moi je veux bien j'adore boire
l'eau savonneuse oui après quand je
parle je fais des bulles de quoi
s'agit-il et bien vrai que tu nous
tricote à chaleur
mais vous pouviez pas le dire tout de
suite pato deux phrases il m'a justement
envoyée il ya un mois des pelotes de
laine je me mets au travail tout de
suite ralliés on va l'avoir notre bonne
vieille
vous savez tricoter
et vous vous savez celle qui ne savent
pas je vais apprendre à monter les
mailles et puis le poids le plus simple
point bus
voilà mais qu'est ce que vous faites là
tous les deux notre garde au oui moi
j'ai très envie d'apprendre à tricoter
et moi aussi porte à casimir tu restes
avec moi mais françois tu vas lessive et
mon casque faut que bon je veux
on fait un petit noeud pour bien tenir
la laine
locale l'autre aiguille sous son bras et
on pique
dans la première my on passe la laine en
tire
et cette laine là on la repasse du
suisse a fait deux mailles on continue
et on refait la même chose chaque et
trois mâles et ainsi de suite on va en
faire quatre ou fait un petit
échantillon toujours quand on commence à
tricot 4 my et voilà nous passent par
dessus
alors le poids mousse
le point mousse c'est pour faire les
tricots au potimarron qui fait toujours
de l'estrie galarnière c'est la même
chose le point mousse on pique à nouveau
on repasse la laine
et là on lâche la maille on pique pas
cela l'aide non lâche la maille en
piques à l'endroit on passe la laine on
lâche la mare gros soir
en pic il arrive qu'à skieurs et puis
notamment le troisième rang j'ai besoin
de tes mesure
alors on prend la largeur et la hauteur
voilà ça c'est très simple tu sois à
l'aise avec les félons pour que tu viens
show oui oui alors là ça nous fait 66
voilà tu peux retourner à ton travail
dans le jeu
tiens
tu veux pas essayer toi même de tenir
les aiguilles et de piqué
voilà
tu passes les fils
et tu sors tu as my très bien à temps tu
la laisses tomber voilà sur pick voilà
très bien vous voyez ça n'est pas
compliqué de tricoter c'est très facile
ces mêmes enfantin c'est même tellement
simple que je vais aller me tricoter mon
chandail moi même ouais ouh là là
j'aimerais bien voir le résultat de
votre tournée mon chat la mine oui et ce
n'est pas faute au monsieur du snob à
j'ai hâte d'aller à la pêche à c'est ma
distraction préférée c'est une joie ce n
est qu elle sorte de pêche pratiquée
vous
le plus simple j'ai un fils et je le
jette de ma petite barre et je tire
ensuite et je ramène de jolis petits
poissons de toutes les couleurs mais je
les regarde jamais aucun non non non non
je le contemple parfois même je les
photographie et puis ensuite je les
rejette
voilà un geste qui vous honorent moins
cher et 1000 c'est ce qui s'appelle
avoir l'esprit sportif quant à moi ma
distraction préférée c'est la recherche
la table des oeuvres d'un ma vie entière
est consacrée à l'art avec un grand tas
comme jamais pour sûr mais qu'a reçues
ou ah
mais attendez monsieur du club on dirait
on dirait un vieux filets de pêche
abandonnés aux médias je vais pouvoir
m'en servir le mien à plusieurs trous ça
ne remplacera mais attendez mon chéri
m'y attendais non non non non non vous
fait voir ce n'est pas banal filets de
pêche c'est une toile d'araignée géante
de super luxe retravaillé par un génial
artiste or quand le maire devait
réaliser là donc dans la communion de la
becque de l'homme c'est le summum on ne
peut pas aller plus loin c'est moi ce
sera la perle de 1000 fans ont hâte sans
vouloir vous vexer monsieur duchesneau
vous faites des erreurs c'est un vieux
que les pêches non je vais pouvoir m'en
servir alors je l'emportent vous n'en
avez pas besoin que jamais de la vie je
ne laisserai jamais une oeuvre d'art
dans les mains d'un facteur pêcheurs un
culte à rend à soyez polis et ceux du
stock voilà maille à l'endroit une
maille à l'envers
index souple petit doigt décontractée
c'est très bien l'arrière de mon
chandail est presque terminée maille à
l'envers mme mais qu'est ce que vous
faites arrêter vous êtes en train
d'abîmer l'avant de mon chandail qu'est
ce que tu dis mais oui c'était un
chandail mais c'est un chandail spéciale
à maïs souples et aéré pour porter sous
tous les climats or jamais donné tant de
mal je suis navré casimir contenu ne
demandons qu'à réparer notre bêtise
bon ben vous savez tricoter pour sur moi
entre échos alors là je n'y connais rien
à j'avoue que c'est un art qui manque
totalement à ma palette ça me fait rien
c'est très simple je vais vous apprendre
prenez ni lui chacun oui d'accord voilà
pour vous facteurs prenez ça monsieur
l'histoire et vous suivez les conseils
d'une maille à l'endroit connaissent ou
qui n'attend pas d'un acteur de
père maille à l'endroit une maille à
lombez passer devant derrière maille à
l'envers à l'endroit derrière un 3par à
gauche voilà à droite à gauche à droite
à gauche c'est bien à droite à gauche
bon eh bien maintenant toujours tout
droit